Magnus tomorrow you're moving on to play
the young Notre back of do Satora of a
world rapid Champion how excited do you
get for matches like that against
players who potential World Championship
level talents so how excited do you get
for matchups like that
he's worst he was championed in 2021 and
I took it back in 2022.
you're right I'm sorry
um
you have quite a lot of chairs in your
room have we noticed uh you're not gonna
sell any of them on eBay for your fans
at all or give them any away as prizes
no uh uh where I am on the rare
occasions that I I do streams I need the
chairs for the idiots in the back
which uh David David has been one of
them in the past for sure